est ce que tu es prêt pour une interwiew
bisounours ballon interview
[Musique]
bisounours vous aviez quel âge pour
votre premier bisou
fait pas aux trois quarts est un c'est
quand la dernière fois vous avez pleuré
à semaine dernière pourquoi au parloir
non je me suis coincé dans une lourde je
suppose un doigt dans une bourde way est
une contrepétrie c'est pas un chagrin
d'amour ou non non non et votre couleur
préférée c'est quoi c'est le noir est
votre fleur préférée
à pâquerettes prend la
cij en cabas vous avez attendu longtemps
avant d'offrir votre virginité à une
jeune fille
douze ans
c'est quoi la soirée idéale à 2 pour
vous
elle et moi c'est tout cent personnes
doute un astucieux ou 30 ans
vous préférez quand harry rencontre
sally ou nuits blanches à seattle est
nul on chassieu et amélie poulain vous
avez aimé je peux regarder
vous avez pleuré à la fin de grand bleu
vous parle qui n ont plus
qu est la chose la plus romantique que
vous ayez faite dans votre vie à
permettre un silencieux
offrir des fleurs rares et des
pâquerettes idiote je te dis
c'est quand la dernière fois qu'une
femme vous a blessé enfin au sens figuré
bien sûr
6 mois
à 6 mois voilà elle a fait quoi à penser
grand chose mais elle a fait ouais
t'as ta blessé samedi contre caen n'a
pas changé l'eau des pâquerettes et pour
lui
c'est peut-être un détail pour vous mais
ce soir il est bon
ce soir il fait france gall soirées
thématiques
et bien il est lassana blaquart ce soir
que nous accueillons
vous appellerai comment votre premier
enfant
théo
et bien c'est dans les bras de qui que
vous vous sentez le mieux tant mieux
c'est quoi votre définition de l'amour
je la cherche encore
et votre peluche favorite c'est là
qu'est l'inde et des requins
avec tes petits enfants ce
bureau pdg
rejoint aussi c'est sa chambre c'est un
outil d'une allée chez sa nourrice mèche
de cheveux assez un petit nous nous un
petit bisounours booba au bout bol plein
jour
et dans dans le merveilleux monde de
disney sait quel personnage préféré
[Musique]
ça balance pas mal à paris
qui n'avez vous jamais osé dire je
t'aime à
ma fille
on s'envoie un petit bisou la loi
alors
la dernière fois vous allez pleurer
je crois vraiment fonctionné comme je
crois un couple heureux
à quel âge avait offert votre corps à
une jeune fille karine personnel
quel âge
c'était très tôt très tôt non
13 ans j'étais déjà musclé comme ça
j'ai vu berry sébastien
havot devriez ça vous plairait il est
beau le chien pour vous c'est quoi la
soirée idéale à 2
à 2 à 2 dans une voiture avec un gros
joint oui
quelle est la chose la plus romantique
que vous ayez faite dans votre vie
je vous sors des fleurs à ma mère a très
bien
il aime sa mère
vraiment ri vous entendez mieux avec les
gens de quel signe
façon logique
je crois pas ça
mais rien à faire vous aimez les petits
chatons sur internet sur internet non
vraiment on aimait bien les petits chats
félicien francis cabrel exercice
alors
vous l'appellerait comment votre premier
bébé
souleymane peut-être dans les bras de
qui vous sentez vous le mieux
les bras pour fait à
pudique vous avez quelque chose à dire à
votre maman là
je veux en avoir après vous allez
souvent bien sûr il faut tous les jours
super important art est vrai qu il y en
a que c'est bien
non
ça fait du bien ça va apaiser le débat
et c'est noël tous c'est quoi votre
couleur préférée
le noir est votre fleur préférée celle
que geoffroy ma femme la rose
est un sentimental on découvre en europe
on connaît pas vrai que l'on est à 13,6
en faire du reggae
c'est quoi pour vous la soirée idéale à
c'est gênant répond pas
lâche moi je mange pas de ce poids là
c'est pas le fan qui va manger le
soir idéal c'est quoi c'est pour me dire
tu as mangé toi angleterre les meilleurs
accords pas de tir debout bord n'est pas
vue comme river gone la chose la plus
romantique que vous ayez faite dans
votre vie rohff
il a offert un bracelet
c'est ça
c'est quand j'ai fait la demande en
mariage ouais à l'ayraultport arrêt au
steward
quand vous étiez petit votre doudou
c'était quoi
un pas de deux
sections temps qu'ils quittaient tango
dos comme
d'hab on peut jouer ton qui est beaucoup
est ce que
[Rires]
le rend ma vie avec mes yeux
est ce que vous êtes désespéré par la
disparition des ours polaires et des
pandas
non non
faites vous un bisou à l'est oh que
c'est beau
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux